what's happening there reject nation we
got ourselves a cinematic trailer for a
game that looks like a dream come true
in some ways i've always said that they
should do like a superhero version of
super smash brothers that is not exactly
what this is but it made me think of
that when i saw the trailer a couple
months ago we got the cinematic one for
multiverses if you guys can leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated and i
want to thank established titles for
sponsoring this video more on them after
the reaction in the meantime let's get
to it
[Music]
[Music]
computer what's my location kevin conroy
man
hey dude what's going on here yes
[Music]
[Music]
hey
oh no
[Music]
yes
[Music]
we are the crystal gems
[Music]
because you look like your name might be
slobber
jared
[Music]
oh man
wow
fantastic
look out below
there is i don't know what's happening
here but this looks like a job
oh my yes superman and i are giant i
love it oh
meet this hero
for our
brawling pleasure
hey steven velma fit the human
cool alpha
nice wow
oh
thoughts are brewing your wb cinematic
universe is finally truly coming again
that's right into the server keep trying
and i think you finally found one
all right guys we'll talk about it but
first the word from established titles
but before we do that we're gonna need
you boys and girls to become a lord
right now now you're probably thinking
isn't a lord some type of royalty i will
not when you check out today's videos
sponsor established titles they come in
a big scottish alert has never been
easier established title packs come with
at least one square foot of dedicated
land and a nifty certificate with your
unique plot number so you can look upon
the exact location of your land they
work with multiple global reforestation
charities and plot a tree with every
order plus they make great last minute
gifts and officially change your name to
lord or lady and even put it on a credit
card or a plane ticket established
titles is running a bag sale right now
bagpipes
and if you use the code real rejects
you'll get an additional 10 off your
order so go to establish
establishedtitles.com
rio rejects my code and officially
change your name to lord or lady today
yeah i thought that was absolutely
excellent i mean just seeing superman
iron giant together i'm sure that makes
you especially a happy camper iron giant
being one of your favorite movies like i
said earlier this has that like super
smash brothers uh vibe when you watch
like the other trailer we saw some more
of the game play of watching these
superheroes come together and i love
that they got the like these voice
actors here for it it doesn't sound like
some you know half-assed cartoon or
something like that you know this sounds
like you get the real voice over talents
to participate in this video game so you
really feel like the characters are
being brought to life like the actual
characters and they get to have the
universes collide together this seems
like just a genuinely fun time to be
doing this and yeah wb keeps trying to
do like their own weird cinematic
universe of like all the intellectual
properties it seems like and this this
seems like a great avenue of what to go
down i'm excited to pick it up seems
like a really fun party game john what
was your favorite part oh goodness
gracious me i mean i i was overjoyed not
only of course to see people like batman
and harley quinn and superman but like i
love too that you get the cartoon
characters coming in from like adventure
time and steven universe and looney
tunes obviously and yeah it's like
something about this gave me a warmer
and more sort of joyous feeling than
even like i didn't even hate space jam
2. like a lot of people do yeah but you
know it's like they're crashing all
their stuff into this big old multiverse
and this feels like a way more natural
setting for that and it makes me excited
to see what they might be able to add to
because like you've said you know
getting these characters into a super
smash type environment is already really
fun but also with the current
capabilities that games have and
downloadable content and stuff like that
like these are imaginative characters
with a lot of imaginative moves i would
imagine they can uh you know throw into
a fight like you see jake you know the
dog turn into this giant form of himself
turn into a car those things i'm like
how many of those are we gonna get to do
with these different characters because
that's really fun and that's embracing
the cartoonishness of it all as well as
the brawl you know well it seems like
they're bringing the characters to life
because even with shaggy getting that
like super ability somehow feels like
the way how you give them shaggy like a
super power i don't really know scooby
doo that well is that something you know
that he does
no no he eats big sandwiches and catches
scooby doo but the fact that he got like
so enraged by the loss of a sandwich
feels
in tune with the character as opposed to
just give shaggy something to do that's
really powerful because he needs to be
able to fight in this game yeah do in
the cinematic trailer shows that they
are paying attention to who these
characters are as opposed to just having
skins of the characters in here and and
just the abilities and and to me that's
a big part of what feels like this could
be something pretty special to pick up a
controller for and actually dive into a
little bit more like even harley and taz
because we know how harley quinn loves
her dogs loves her vicious dogs so it
makes sense that she would take such a
liking to taz as well and you know
harley quinn is a character that i often
like to play as in the injustice video
games and she's gonna be in the suicide
squad as well so this is like the third
video game i know of that she's going to
be featured in i'm i'm assuming she's
more than that but in terms of like
these big video games it's kind of cool
how you're getting these different
representations of harley all across
these different mediums too so i wonder
like what other characters they'll be
adding into the fold as this progresses
you know calling it multiverses so
that's also that's a very clever title
that's a very clever title because we
all know that key word of multiverse and
called multiverses you got to respect
you got to respect good branding for
your video game that's a great title and
it's going to teach people how to spell
verses yeah it's true of putting verses
but no it's like you can expand this to
game like the way how super smash
brothers did but they just kept adding
more and more characters in there which
made it more and more exciting so you
can get like the flash and cyborg
aquaman pennywise michael jordan
yeah yeah the matrix character is
everyone you could do that and that's
what's exciting about it and the fact
that they pay attention to the details
of the characters makes me that much
more invested in it again
character versus just the you know skin
avatars
guys what do you think about this uh
multiverses trailer are you excited to
play this game leave your thoughts down
below you can subscribe click that bell
leave a like and thank you to
established titles for sponsoring this
video